[Music]
hey timmy
hi ray
all right so betty
betty uh last last year
after we did the video shoot the uh the
gofundme campaign we did for you guys
yeah generated like almost thirty
thousand dollars
which you got in pieces and uh
you guys fix up the roof of your house
and you got some new windows
and uh what are the things i know that
you had some medical expenses too right
lorraine had a heart attack yeah and
then timmy had a heart attack just
recently right yeah
is that where is that what most of the
money was used for
i'm sorry what was the money what did
you guys use the money for
well i used money for the 10 and then
siding
i did fix one i did fix one room up i
picked my laundry room up
okay
i do that's great so let me ask you a
little bit about
your lives here you grew up in this
house
no i grew up in that house over the
across from
rhoda and if and he was falling in
this phone in everything then i had to
then i had bought this trailer and moved
everything in
what i had oh this is a trailer hey yeah
to try it with the bill
i built them runs on two of them is that
right
how many how many children were there in
your family
almost 16 i think
16.
and uh yeah where did all the kids
move off to because not everyone lived
here right yeah well some of them
yeah someone was born here then
some of them out there in virginia
why were they born in different houses
why were they born in different houses
you said some were in virginia and some
were here you got that's when my mom and
daddy live at
mama
so your parents moved yeah from virginia
to west virginia
uh-huh oh i see i see and what was it
like growing up here
i thought i was growing up here
that was like a little kid went out i
guess it was a little key
well i mean it's a very isolated little
street you guys are on what was it like
did you have friends did you have
friends
yeah we had friends along until they all
growed up and got married and
moved towards the house
and where is everyone today of those 16
children where where is everyone i know
that freddie passed away
well my mom had some miscarriage
oh i see and then i lost barbara
my dad
timmy and lorraine what what what do you
do you remember your
your siblings who passed away who what
siblings do you guys lose
kelly kevin you all passed away huh
tell me a little bit why you know you're
not bad
we don't realize
tell me about the personalities here
tell me about ray and timmy and
lorraine who else who else
freddie was around hey hey yeah
who who's the biggest troublemaker
right
yeah they look like brothers
and your dogs look very well taken care
of
you guys take care of your dogs yeah
thank you my dog sorry
my dog my little dog was hardly when i
was in hospital
and when i came home she ate you guys
get lonely here
living you guys live like by yourselves
here on this street
do you do you get lonely here yeah my
mommy lived over there
my mommy and daddy live at work but i
passed away when when did your parents
pass away how long ago
oh mommy down like waiting
i'm not seeing something my daddy died
yeah 20s i
forgot what year it was it's been so
long
yeah but you guys are happy here no yeah
you guys live by yours you know with you
just it's just family here right
right no no one got married no
i promised my mommy i promised my mommy
i would get married
i would take i was going to stay home
take your
right lauren kim and i did so you take
care of the family more than anyone
right
yeah i took care of funny more anybody
else do you yeah
have you guys traveled have you been to
other parts of the country no
you never left uh have you ever left odd
west virginia no
really even i don't travel nowhere
you guys go to church i'm teaming the
wind goes to church right down here
i'm sorry hi happy birthday
just don't go to church here well back
right with the kid and
if i was a kid and he was going to go to
church down there
one family was making fun at him so he
just he wouldn't go back
oh you guys get made fun of sometimes
yeah yeah
timmy you had a heart attack recently
yeah oh
yeah but they couldn't
they couldn't do that test on him oh no
they do also sound
okay
and then lorraine had a heart attack as
well uh
yeah earlier this year or last year i
can't remember
yeah last year lorraine looks good
though she was working hard while today
for once and the heart got strong and
everything does it all
lorraine was talking the other day when
i came by yeah it was the most talkative
hey hey hey
man
hey
hey you look good though
i'm not here baby hey
timmy tell me about your dogs my dog
my girl is walking to pain he work
everybody can
how many dogs do you have i got four
four of them they look well taken here
so you know before we shot that last
video i did a a
little research on your family history
and it looks like your parents were
double first cousins
yeah um which might explain some of the
some of the defects that that ray and
lorraine and freddie and but
i suspect there's probably something
else going on too maybe something in the
environment in the water
or something what would you guys ever
have any ideas about what what what i
mean was ray
ray doesn't really speak why do you
suppose that might be
that kid won't like that you were just
born that way
yeah he's born out of wine nobody wants
to think
he wants to yeah timmy is a cousin right
no timmy's or nathan a nephew okay
so timmy's a nephew but he might say
he's a brother
yeah he's here he's like a brother right
yeah he's my brother
part of the family you feeling better
it's good
you've been in hospital before
not for a long time
tell me about your parents your mom and
dad how what kind of people were they
yeah yeah did you did your father work
yeah they were good oh my your father
was a coal miner
and mom stayed home and took care of the
the 15 16 kids
yeah hey
do you remember tell me about your
parents were they what kind of people
were they
they were they were nice they were nice
too yeah
you want to show me your garden where do
you guys go to eat what do you do you go
to uh walmart and get some food
sometimes or what do you do for food
for food i'll go get them well i see
i'll go different store get food
and who does the cooking i do the
cooking you do all the cooking
they used to cook till you start
till you start getting burned yeah
you get burned in the kitchen yeah do
you have a garden here
yeah i've got a guard you want to show
me your garden draw it out there
i'd love to see it right you want to
show me the garden
show me your garden
we'll be right back let's go look at the
garden
[Applause]
ray where's the garden
your garden's over here show me the
garden
you wanna show me
ray show me your show me the house a
little bit you want to show me inside
show me show me inside ray
this is your bedroom
here's your kitchen
how many rooms are there okay
two two
revolved
hey
[Music]
hey
what all right
tell me something about yourself what
what hey hey
what's he trying to show me yeah
yeah and yeah dear dear
dear hey call them
you have deer here right
here here
what kind of animals you see here you
ever see bear
now a couple years ago we seen my
bubby bear and mommy bear climate just
climbing pine tree under
really yeah and the daddy's bird was
going cross the creek
they're a whole now
the birds out here too
yeah i believe i've heard that before
you stop can you show me your snuff
so you like to shoot tobacco
how old is ray
how old are you ray
62 no
16 67
oh
[Music]
betty what were the what were the best
years of your life here uh-huh what were
the best years of your life
well i don't know
you ever get lonely here do you ever you
ever get lonely here
sometimes i do do you guys have friends
outside of the family
they don't already come around
yeah so ray's an interesting character i
i suspect that ray is much smarter than
he appears
he may not speak but i think ray
understands a lot of what we're saying
do you understand
what you talked about ray when i when i
ask you questions you understand what
i'm saying right
yeah you just don't have the ability to
to speak right
yeah yeah but where he's smart ray
understands i think
right you ever have a girlfriend hey hi
who's that
no no no
oh no
oh
would be nice having a little more room
have you having your own bedroom a
little more privacy
yeah next door
tell me a little bit more about ray i'm
fascinated with ray
tell me a little more about ray is there
anything interesting about ray that we
don't know
no there's got to be something
what are his interests interests is ray
is very interested in anything
no no
it's so nice to come here and get
greeted so warmly when i showed up ray
and timmy came over give me a hug give
me a nice
put their arms around me if he knows
people die
i've known you guys probably about 15
years now i think when we first met
there was a police officer for raleigh
county that brought me here
oh yeah you like to watch television ray
what's your favorite show ray they have
eight
love cowboys you like cowboys ray
i i really i like to tear i don't hardly
watch tv
not through the daytime but you know
what i'll watch tv tonight
and i can't because i fall to sleep too
quick and your typical day is what
you'll spend you'll you'll wake up in
the morning and do what make breakfast
yeah get boiled yeah we'll make
breakfast and then what
do you wanna you know get up do the
laundry yeah i'll get up clean the house
will be here
and ray and timmy lorraine we'll do what
we're the ones that got a little bored
get me together riding
then he goes even where's my dishes and
stuff every time i've come by here you
guys are always just sitting on your
porch here
yes we're always saying hey yeah so if
you had a little more money
um you did a beautiful job on the roof
and then the windows and
and the siding on some of the house but
uh what else would you do here you'd fix
up the floors maybe
yeah maybe paint it yeah yeah
i wouldn't draw the paint if you had the
house next door that would that would
make things easier you'd be less crowded
here right
yeah it's right next door and the
neighbors here are
are good with you they're nice to you
the neighbors
you can't get neighbors do nothing for
you really
you have a good relationship with your
neighbors or no we don't do that
well she didn't want why do you
see that lady when that's right in that
white car
so you take a place and you will not
check like you got excuses go somewhere
else
everybody stays to themselves yeah
did you it did you have any friends
outside of the family or it's just
it's just you guys yeah
and laurie daughter and their kids and
y'all
you have any words of wisdom to share
with uh with the world i mean what's the
most
important thing you've learned in your
life
not much
[Laughter]
all right you guys timmy nice seeing you
again i'm glad you're healthy
lorraine same with you i'm glad you're
you're you're feeling good you're
looking great
yeah she is now i thought i thought
we'll look at here for a while
yeah you don't want to lose anybody you
guys are a tight little family yeah
if they hadn't heard what i would do i
probably could
i don't ray great seeing you again
and betty thank you very much okay
you're welcome all right
did you used to have an outhouse at one
time
a long time ago we do yeah that's going
on there
yeah i didn't we had a bathroom over
here you want to show me the other house
anything pull down
show me
what do you do for fun ray what do you
do
show me around the house what's in the
back you have a creek in the back
show me
you wanna show me the creek show me the
creek
oh beautiful creek
daylilies rhododendrons
sycamores beautiful
this is i think where i photographed you
15 years ago whoa you're peeing ray
you gotta go you gotta go right
great seeing you ray